enfin avril 1997 quelques jours après
cette annonce faite par le président
Jacques Chirac j'ai décidé de dissoudre
l'Assemblée nationale la gauche
s'organise à la hâte communiste
socialiste se retrouve aujourd'hui pour
signer un document commun les délais
sont courts pour espérer remporter un
maximum de sièges à ces élections
législatives anticipées un mois avant
l'échéance électorale le Parti
socialiste le Parti communiste les Verts
les radicaux de gauche et le Mouvement
des Citoyens Sally à la manœuvre le
premier secrétaire du PS Lionel Jospin
c'est surtout un moment d'un mouvement
de rassemblement auquel je consacre
beaucoup de soins et d'un rassemblement
pluraliste parce que tous ceux qui sont
des candidats du changement dans cette
campagne
après avoir débattu
dégage des positions communes la gauche
plurielle est née entre position commune
et divergence l'objectif en tout cas est
le même pour tous atteindre la majorité
absolue dans l'hémicycle au gouvernement
de Jacques Chirac et au premier tour des
législatives les résultats sont plutôt
encourageants les forces de gauche
devancent celles de droite 40,1% des
suffrages contre 36,4 gonflé à bloc
chaque branche de la gauche pluriel est
à pied d'oeuvre et désormais plus qu'un
accord électoral c'est un accord de
gouvernement qui est envisagé ça peut
aller vite très vite pour reprendre la
formule de Jospin la semaine dernière
l'alliance va porter ses fruits la
gauche remporte le second tour des
législatives les Verts font leur entrée
pour la première fois à l'Assemblée
nationale et Lionel Jospin est nommé par
Jacques Chirac au poste de Premier
ministre le contact a été bon avec le
président de la République c'est la
troisième cohabitation sous la Cinquième
République et chose promise chose due le
gouvernement Jospin est pluriel
socialiste communiste vers radicaux de
gauche tout sont représentés dans les
différents ministères entre la mise en
place des 35 heures l'instauration du
PACS et de la couverture maladie univers
la coalition est fructueuse mais les
relations sont parfois houleuses à
Calais pour la grande manifestation
tiplan sociaux un fossé c'est creusé
entre le Parti socialiste ses
partenaires de la gauche pluriel et même
sa gauche extrême le traitement social
des nombreux licenciements et les
mauvais résultats aux dernières
municipales accentue le malaise
politique de la gauche gouvernementale
Europe nucléaire autonomie de la Corse
les sujets de discorde se multiplient à
tel point que le ministre de l'Intérieur
Jean-Pierre Chevènement démissionne pour
lui les choses sont claires la gauche
pluriel n'existe plus et je crois que
elle est une formule épuisée parce que
elle reposait d'abord sur une ambiguïté
un accord à géométrie variable entre
d'une part le Parti socialiste et les
Verts d'autre part le Parti socialiste
et communiste et puis le Parti
socialiste le MDC etc et puis on voit
bien aujourd'hui que le Parti socialiste
est dépassé par sa créature la gauche
est éclatée résultat un an plus tard
pour l'élection présidentielle chaque
formation présente son propre candidat
mais aucun d'entre eux n'atteindra le
second devancé par Jean-Marie Le Pen
[Musique]